hey do you guys want to try the new beef
shavings bowl and I'm like
the naming come on you know what my
feelings I can go for some beef shavings
right now oh I'm so hungry
[Music]
so do you use AI in any of your
businesses not yet oh or maybe maybe I
might be using it but I don't know I'm
actually using it oh interesting oh
because different departments different
AI is being being used I think or maybe
your lawyer's using it
laughs
your verbs got
us here clack clack when he's talking to
you on the phone I use Chad GPT a lot
for my emails I started to yeah rewrite
a lot of it yeah because when you write
professional emails it's just like [__]
I hate that wording right so I'll just
write an outline please create an email
introducing myself and this is the
criteria that I'm looking for oh tight
wow and it'll be so professional like to
who may make or whatever best regards
whatever yeah so your children's account
uh professional porn Watcher and jerk
off
it goes by things you've said on this
show looking for funding
it's like I like it when the anime
chicks have huge [__]
signature at the end
of course well this email captured my
Essence it's like when they come to the
ceiling bro
[Laughter]
it's like to his landlord from the
freaking to me
are you are you looking at it like okay
this could help my business this could
be a disrupter model for like a lot of
my waste in my businesses yeah I'm
looking at it as in where people can use
it
how you schedule people like hey these
are if you're looking through the data
who's who's producing the most sales
who's you know how are we getting are we
getting a lot of returning customers
when this this this team of staff is
working out so I think we'll read into
those things that we can't oh we can't
see but the ultimate Optimizer yeah
exactly just helping us optimize the
business a lot better that's I think AI
is going to do a lot of that's gonna be
really tight so Chipotle is looking at
doing it right a lot of different fast
food places are looking at doing it they
want to do basically help to automate
automate the back end like you know
cutting up a bunch of vegetables and
chicken and [__] like make yeah making
it all they already have
um an AI or a robot not AI but a robot
called chippy and it just makes tortilla
chips for them
oh they make fresh chips those chips are
good those chips are really good that's
like my favorite thing is Chipotle is
their [__] chips chips and guac I
like to guac too I like the guac people
who hate the guac are nuts
guac baby you know people hate on the
Block yeah what is this Chipotle egg
walk and I'm like what who says that
[__] [__] who are like it's just
an authentic Mexican why don't you just
grab them by the throat and punch him in
the [__] face dude I will next time I
want to bring back uh frying things in
lard
no dude it's stopped in our generation
yeah that's when it was the unkosher
non-hallal days oh yeah that's right
like these people are killing themselves
on McDonald's food let's make it take
longer to kill themselves because in the
90s they they pushed the whole seed oil
[__] yeah so then they and then now
we're finding out now we're fine
now we're finding out it causes all this
heart disease your system can't break it
down as easy right A lot of people died
from canola oil what the [__] is canola
anyway man canola is not even a [__]
vegetable dude that shit's a flower seed
oh [__] Chipotle is also looking at
implementing an AI power demand based
Cooking System right so it's still it
tells the store staff what to cook and
when to cook it like based on algorithms
for like wherever they're they're at and
with the demand like Wednesdays at 11
prepare for it be prepared for the lunch
brush because I'm ready because I bet
there's a lot of waste that happens with
that right tons of waste where like they
overestimate how much food they're gonna
need but they have a lot of data exactly
what they sold yeah yeah that's nice is
it legal yet to like lay somebody off
using AI
yeah
like because AI replaced them I mean
like because like AI is basically the
one delivering the bad news oh yeah and
then they're allowed to like talk and
ask questions like do I get servants but
they're just talking to a [__]
wouldn't you rather be like go by AI
than this [__] that they do
sometimes yeah probably probably like
when I watch hard knocks on my favorite
shows about the NFL like when they cut
players yeah it's just like just cut me
dude don't [__] give me a story yeah
about how much you value me and [__]
it's like a Money Ball when he lets the
the player go yeah exactly just cut me
treat me like a man cut me yeah do it
quick so McDonald's we all know we did a
story about this where they they're
working on like a completely automated
McDonald's right yeah but McDonald's is
working with IBM to further accelerate
the development and deployment of their
automated order taking technology so
like just not having the person at the
window oh it would be automated
McDonald's is already pretty automated
yeah because when you go in there's like
those kiosk things already yeah and it's
like there's like four of them and then
this there's only like one or two people
working the front whereas before it was
like the other way around the screen
that says your food's in progress making
and when it's done it's like they're
just there for the people that go I
can't it's not it doesn't
yeah you always see somebody having like
a weird Anonymous problem yeah dude you
guys know who yum brands is yeah yep you
work with them
they own Taco Bell and KFC oh Pizza Hut
wow they got a lot so you want to crush
them yeah Long John Silver
damn already
they've already deployed Ai and machine
learning in approximately 3 000 of their
stores in the United States and with
this Tech the stores can accurately
predict how much food's needed cutting
back on waste wow huge what if imagine
if like Arby's did that and the AI came
back and said you guys don't need to buy
anything everyone hates your [__]
nobody's buying anything it's all waste
is the Arby's just burns it down
Sam guns it obliterates all locations it
collaborates with the [__] drones
Army AIS and it just does all the
[__] nuke strikes on all the RVs All
Over America like why did we give the
Arby's nukes we were so we were so
stupid
it was too powerful
when's the last time you guys actually
ate Arby's though I had it not too long
ago I had a few months back not too long
ago yeah it is good I'm just making fun
of it I don't think I've ever had Arby's
what it's good yeah
they're limited item they do you know
they don't do Burgers right they don't
sell Burgers they put a wagy burger out
huh
I bet it's good it's pretty exciting
it's real whack the wagy Burger's good
I'm not an Arby's hitter either and
they're they're horseradish sauce is
like banging huh what is it about like
Arby's is good but it's like fun to make
fun of it it's like it's like it's like
the Nickelback of Jon Stewart did it
yeah oh is that what it is Daily Show if
you guys watch The Daily Show like I did
Jon Stewart would [__] all over her why
did he [__] on it it's just funny
because he was funny as [__] it's like
the first time I saw that was Simpsons
it is also weird to be in a roast beef
yeah are you gonna roast beef or like a
turkey sandwich dude yeah the kids got
stranded on an island because the bus
like went into the water and then the
kids were like I'm so hungry I get a
horse and then some other kid goes I'm
stronger I could eat Arby's and all the
kids wait he's hungry
they're like dang because it's not it's
a rare sight to see when you see in
Arby's right like you've only seen those
like when you go to the customer base
you're like oh you know it's not like I
remember there was one like in Hollywood
Boulevard or whatever that was that one
yeah by Nickelodeon the one where
everybody knows your name yeah yeah
because nobody else is there yeah you're
the only one and then there'll be like
one like on the way to Pechanga Casino
or some [__] there's always like Morongo
or whatever but I don't know any other
like I don't see them anywhere anymore
well they also have weird it's like hey
do you guys want to try the new beef
shavings bowl and I'm like
the naming come on
I can go for some beef shavings right
now oh I'm so hungry
you know what my friends do it dude you
know what my guilty pleasure fast food
that's that's like unapologetically low
quality what's that and I don't want
them to go away huh wiener schnitzel
I get the set where you get the chili
fry a corn dog and then the hamburger or
I think it was a chili dog yeah chili
fry chili cheeseburger yeah and then I
add a corn dog to that mini corn dogs no
vegetables in any of them dude and when
you were there it's like hey walking
weird so I hate my [__] life what do
you want
jeez I see you hate yours what can I get
for you and it's always funny when like
one goes out of business and another
business comes and takes over because
that's to maintain the stupid ass
there's one in Vegas it's like a Philly
cheesesteak place but then the buildings
like this I'm like oh you used to be a
wieners
that's like the Noodle World on Atlantic
remember it was a Bob's Big Boy they
kept the Bobs so they kept the big ass
thing when uh when uh a man converts
into a woman
great now we just gotta delete the whole
video
oh yeah that is the same yeah there's
some things that stay stick around right
now what do you think I think so I I
hope like a couple structural things to
correct yeah sometimes they're still a
wiener schnitzel I hope certain things
like that stay and some come back like I
want orange julius to come back yeah
bring that back is it gone no this is
still have some yeah where really I
don't see that every Dairy Queen sells
the actual Julius drink still I love
Dairy no I remember the score or like
yeah yeah where they had the [__] the
Mojo potato fries kind of thing
yeah I want that [__]
um I want um well Foster Freeze is still
around Foster Freeze but then they used
to be their only store yeah they still
have that in Glendora do they have one
Foster Freeze sign that isn't peeling
and [__] nope
yeah that's right by the gym yeah all
the Altadena milk Sands started looking
vintage like that oh yeah that's so true
it's in their brand Bible
it has to match it has
to help appeal it has to be awesome you
see a guy just chiseling right before
putting the grand opening ribbon
[Music]
thank you
foreign